we can talk now to the chair of global
public health at edinburgh university
professor
debbie srider thank you so much for
being on the programme
um the prime minister of course laying
out his plan
for look now and easing tomorrow how
cautious do you think he needs to be and
what do you think can happen
well the thing to say is there's light
ahead and we should be optimistic
because of the vaccines as a medium to
long-term way out of this if we look at
israel we are seeing that once they have
gotten down to vaccinating
those in their 20s and their 30s they're
seeing actually
that numbers are falling and so there is
a way to suppress this virus
and to stop severe disease with our
vaccines however
we are far way off from vaccinating
people in those age groups
hopefully as the health secretary said
by the summer so the question is how do
we ease restrictions in a one-way
process we don't see a third wave over
the next few months while the vaccine's
rolled out
and that requires a strong test trace
isolate system
especially supporting people in
isolating who are testing positive as
well as mass testing to really hit
higher prevalence areas
younger children in scotland and wales
are going to be returning to school
tomorrow return to the classroom
tomorrow it feels like in england the
ambition is to get
all schools back to all pupils on the
8th of march
who do you think it's got the right
approach well
i'm obviously biased because i advise
the scottish government
on their education policies and so i
would agree what we've done
here which is tomorrow having the
younger kids go back and to assess after
several weeks
what has been the impact on transmission
what have we seen in schools
and we were learning from denmark who
are ahead of us several weeks and who
also
have the new variant the new variant is
creating uncertainty which means we need
to go more cautiously
so there is a huge risk with bringing
back all kids at the same time and then
having to shut schools again and we're
trying here to move slowly to move
cautiously and
get kids back as many kids as possible
but in a slow
staged phased way and with testing the
other thing i'd mention and it's an easy
win
for i think england is in scotland we
have allowed children
under the age of 12 to play outside in
groups up to 13.
only two adults can be there but
children can play in groups so we've
seen children doing sledding tennis
football
out in parks and this gives kind of
outdoor play and also a form of kind of
physical education
and that is an easy win because we know
transmission outside is minimal and the
mental health benefits are huge
um you talk about the um vaccine rollout
going well
and we heard just a moment ago from
william hague who said that once
everyone over 50 is vaccinated the top
nine priority groups which we're
expecting by mid-april
he says there wouldn't be much
justification for keeping restrictions
on people
once this group is protected given they
make up 99
of deaths of covid it does feel to many
people i suppose that
there is a good case for lifting
restrictions
yeah i think we all want to lift
restrictions as quickly as possible
i mean i'm craving going out to a party
or somewhere outside my home but i think
the thing to remember is what gets us
with this virus
is the hospitalization rate and how many
people are susceptible
and the hospitalizations do go down to
people in their 30s and 40s
which means that is what we're really
going after of course the deaths but
also the hospitals being full and not
being able to provide
routine care for all the things we need
the nhs for and so i'd say
of course we want to lift restrictions
but it has to be down to the prevalence
of the virus have we got it low enough
to testing positivity are we testing
enough finding cases
as well as are we actually vaccinating
those most at risk of hospitalization
and learning from other countries such
as israel they once they vaccinated
their over 60s they found a lot of under
60s in hospitals too
so we have to be kind of realistic of
what it's going to look like for the
next few months
and what does the data show on the
impact of the vaccine are we starting to
get any indication yet that it's
having an impact yes i think we're
definitely seeing a reduction in
deaths in older age groups you know
people in over 80 since that group has
been covered
over 70s and we know i mean to tell
people i mean a year ago we didn't even
think we'd have a vaccine and now we
have several
and the effectiveness is astonishing
especially of the mrna ones
and so we are in a strong position to
stop severe disease
and even it seems like glimmers of hope
for stopping transmission
so i think where we're heading with this
you know people say when is the pandemic
going to end
well there's a real chance to drive the
numbers super low using vaccines using
outbreak response
and then it's time for britain and along
the way to look across the world and say
the pandemic will only be over if we
look at
poor countries fragile states you know
130 countries don't have any vaccines at
all right now
and so it's a dual responsibility both
at home but also abroad
i mean you mentioned 130 countries
without any vaccine which clearly has
big implications for the global fight
against covet
but at the same time many people in the
uk would say that we shouldn't give
vaccines away until
every adult has had at least one dose
what do you think the right thing to do
would be
this is a really tricky one and i think
it comes down to three arguments why we
have to be
vaccinating at home but also looking
abroad and the first is the moral one
is it right to be vaccinating people in
their 20s and 30s here when you have
health workers dying
in africa because they can't get access
to a vaccine the second one is actually
self-interest
we know that this virus will mutate we
have seen mutations in south africa and
in brazil
which can reduce the effectiveness of
our vaccines
so if we want to be open to the world
and have people coming in
then we need to make sure we're actually
you know watching out for variants
coming in which will emerge if there's
uncontrolled spread of the virus in
other places and the third is we are
seeing russia and china
donating their vaccines to low-income
countries
for clear geopolitical reasons and so
we've heard you know now with g7
um going on that actually you know there
is concern about what will it mean for
the influence of european and north
american countries
if china and russia are seen as being
the most reliable support rather than
western world okay debbie schroeder
thank you very much professor devi
shredder there